tiene un aspecto muy llamativo de esta
situación que estamos viviendo es que
favorece la mera monarca británica que
muere en escocia porque ningún rey
inglés ha muerto de escocia el último
monarca antepasado suyo reinante ya
difunto escocés en el siglo 16 por tanto
esto que estamos viendo hoy es una
ceremonia realmente importante
interesante y además como todo lo que
nos pasa en la sociedad británica
la cultura tan actualizada tiene un
enorme significado
los vínculos que ha tenido la reina
isabel con la cultura escocesa son
importantes si pensamos en el que
llevamos partiendo de lo más básico su
madre la reina isabel la reina madre era
una
escocesa entonces es una familia de una
vieja familia escocesa por lo tanto por
ahí hay una vinculación digamos
sentimental
otro hecho importante a destacar en este
caso a nivel político es bajo la reina
isabel segunda cuando sea cuando han
nacido cuando ha renacido un parlamento
regional en este caso en escocia como
sabemos desde principios del siglo 18 es
de 1707 el parlamento escocés el
parlamento del reino de escocia y el
parlamento del reino inglaterra se unen
en un solo parlamento británico en
westminster y así sigue hasta nuestros
días el parlament el parlamento de
westminster hay electos escoceses y en
la cámara de los lores también están los
lores escoceses pero es bajo el reinado
de isabel segunda y concretamente cuando
era primer ministro tony blair que se
crea un parlamento regional escocés que
si bien no tienen las mismas
atribuciones que un parlamento soberano
sí que ha recogido todo ese acervo
cultural de escocia al que ha estado
también muy apegada a la reina isabel la
familia real y el propio rey carlos iii
otro apunte el mismo nombre que lleva
este nuevo rey
es un nombre que procede de la familia
real escocesa el primer uno de los dos
anteriores cardos carlos primero que un
segundo estuardo reyes de inglaterra
después ya tenían su origen pues
precisamente en este reino donde hoy se
está celebrando el funeral de que la
fallecida
soberana
un último un último apunte
lo que estamos viendo ahora mismo con
estos soldados los arqueros es procesos
de la reina nuestro elemento muy
llamativo que nunca habíamos visto
digamos porque nunca se haya producido
la muerte el monarca británico jim clark
o daniel también digamos que vamos a
analizar un poco de lo que serían estas
nuevas relaciones entre los escoceses no
con el rey carlos o tercero ya la
vicepresidenta del sinn fein en la
republicana michele o'neal afirmó este
martes que su partido el antiguo brazo
político del inactivo irá extiende
entonces su mano amiga al nuevo rey
carlos tercero que esta visita que bueno
que va a mañana irlanda del norte perdón
cambiamos un poco un poco de tema de
cosas el granero porque también esto es
algo muy importante también por supuesto
con esta pues deseo de independencia con
todo lo que tiene que ver con el preside
como el rey podría lo mejor hacer que
estas estas tensiones bajan un poco no
si efectivamente hay
del norte en escocia tenemos unos años
por una mayoría es importante pero
tampoco aplastante he decidido
permanecer en el reino unido y por otro
lado en irlanda del norte tenemos este
problema ha surgido de otro referéndum
que es el referéndum del break sin el
cual se plantea el problema de que
irlanda del norte ha salido del mercado
común por por el hecho del brics y
entonces efectivamente el 3 que el rey
carlos
que aunque no sé evidentemente no se ha
manifestado públicamente sus opiniones
políticas pero creo que todo apunta al
que tanto él como su madre
digamos que seguirán más
europeísta que hubiera evitado tantos
problemas como los que hay ahora
desde luego va a ser su función es de
equilibrar y poner digamos el diálogo
suavidad en donde haya tensión hay una
nueva primera ministra británica
digamos que efectivamente está ante los
reyes está ante una
fijada no puede pasar no depende todo de
él pero yo creo que lo que va a primar
pues es ese talante
de promover el diálogo y evitar las
tensiones y sobre todo respetar la
neutralidad de la corona como
institución aglutinadora ahora claro eso
también quiere hablarlo danielle con
usted porque digamos que son muchas
cambios los que están pasando ahora en
el reino unido el primero pues de todo
lo que tuvo que ver con el primer
ministro boris johnson lo que
desencadenó a su renuncia luego estas
votaciones en el partido conservador
para esta nueva primera ministra liz
rose y después dos días después la
muerte de la reina que conlleva por
supuesto a este nuevo rey su hijo carlos
tercero el rey carlos tercero entonces
digamos una sociedad tan tradicional por
decirlo de alguna manera de la sociedad
británica
convocarán todos estos cambios en la
sociedad y como lo puede digamos
sobrellevar no también hablamos que
tiene una economía pues bastante
delicada no en este punto que también es
uno de los retos principales de la nueva
primera ministra disfraz
sí yo creo que una particularidad de la
sociedad británica es esa esa doble esa
doble cara por un lado una sociedad que
como estamos viendo está muy apegada a
los ritos a la ritualización de lo
político y por otro lado a una sociedad
que es que ha sido vanguardista en
muchísimas cosas si pensamos en el hecho
mismo de la monarquía parlamentaria pues
es la más antigua de europa en muchas de
las grandes medidas del resto de
naciones de occidente han tomado después
está también pues en su sistema político
en muchos aspectos ha sido una sociedad
históricamente
capaz de asimilar el cambio y sin
renunciar a la tradición es una sociedad
que no ha sido revolucionaria es una
sociedad donde no hay una constitución
escrita al uso decimonónica fruto de una
revolución liberal sino que es una
acumulación
de leyes antiquísima que priman la edad
media y que constituyen un corpus que es
lo que se llama la constitución
con lo cual esos gramos eso se le
permite la expresión pues un poco el
carácter
que que da una oportunidad a socia
británica no en un momento de crisis
como éste otros momentos de crisis ha
habido y el reinado de isabel segundo es
un ejemplo yo creo que ella es un muy
buen ejemplo de cómo la corona de esa
posición que parece imperturbable pero
que ha sabido también no ser insensible
digamos ha sido sensible era mantenido
digamos un
sentimiento de constancia o de que de
alguna forma
ponía orden en un mundo que puede ser
desordenado y los cambios que pueda
haber ahora la crisis hay ahora en el
reino unido esto evidentemente aunque
serán los políticos británicos quienes
la tenga que resolver pero qué bueno yo
creo que por terminar pero yo no es malo
que luego reid
una persona de 70 años creo que en este
momento puede dar un sentimiento de una
cierta el fin de cimiento maternal que
había transmitido la reina isabel puede
quizá ser uno de los puntos a favor del
rey carlos que ha vivido él mismo como
príncipe en muchos de esos cambios si
recordamos esa fotografía donde aparece
la coronación de su madre nos podemos
imaginar todo lo que haya vivido durante
este tiempo y ahora ya no nada pues
bastante
adulta y la madurez y en fin yo creo que
es una persona que está a nivel
está preparado para esto de desafíos y
yo creo que la sociedad británica se
está viendo como cómo se vuelca con él